Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家分享一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. On today's episode, I am joined by Francesca Spector, who is a journalist and
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。今天做客节目的嘉宾是Francesca Spector，她是一位记者，也是
author of Alonement. We're thinking about how to do things by yourself more often with joy and in a way that feels really enriching. These are really interesting ideas in psychology, both in undergraduate, master's study, and even in postgraduate doctoral courses, and for that matter, relevant experience roles, means that we can find ourselves starting afresh at different stages of our lives. Stay tuned right to the end for Francesca's top tips for how to begin to be more comfortable with spending time by yourself, even if you're in a relationship or have good support. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent.
《Alonement》一书的作者。我们将探讨如何更频繁地、快乐地、以一种真正充实的方式独自做事情。这些在心理学本科、硕士甚至博士课程中都是非常有趣的课题，而且对于相关经验的角色来说，意味着我们可以在人生的不同阶段重新开始。请务必听到最后，获取Francesca关于如何开始适应独处时光的顶级建议，即使你处于恋爱关系中或拥有良好的支持系统。有这个播客陪伴，你将走上成为合格心理学家的道路。这里是Marianne Trent博士的《准心理学家播客》。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. So people have been in contact with me recently to discuss what to do about doctoral courses and to discuss whether to accept jobs that are, you know, perhaps a couple of hours away or more from where their current lives are and what their current support systems are. And I want to be able to add to the narrative so that when people are making decisions about jobs, that they can do so by being empowered to know that it's okay to do this by themselves. And in that regard, I wanted to invite along a real expert in being alone and being comfortable with that. And so our guest for today is Francesca Spector, and she is a journalist and author of a wonderful book called Alonement. And I really hope that you'll find this episode useful, perhaps for your own uses, if you're starting out or maybe going to be starting out a new chapter of your life in future, but also for client work as well so if people are coming to you with issues of loneliness then how you can think about empowering them to feel more confident in being
你好，欢迎收听《准心理学家播客》。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。最近有人联系我，讨论关于博士课程的问题，以及是否应该接受离目前生活和支持系统较远的工作。我想补充一些观点，让人们在做职业决定时，能够有底气地知道，独自面对这些是没问题的。因此，我邀请了一位真正擅长独处并对此感到自在的专家。今天的嘉宾是Francesca Spector，她是一位记者，也是一本名为《Alonement》的精彩书籍的作者。我真心希望这期节目对你有用，无论你是刚起步，还是未来即将开启人生的新篇章，同时也希望对你的临床工作有所帮助。如果有人带着孤独感来找你，你可以思考如何赋予他们力量，让他们在独处时感到更自信，
alone and when to listen to those feelings of loneliness and to to forge and form connections and plan activities with others so for for many reasons, I hope you'll find it really useful. Francesca is wonderful to listen to and to speak with. And I felt so uplifted from our conversation. So I hope that you will do too. I look forward to catching up with you on the other side. I just want to welcome our guest for today, Francesca Spector. Hi, Francesca. Hi, Marianne. So you are a journalist, but you're also an author of a book that we're going to talk about a little bit later. But your specialism is or has become for one reason or another, about how to be alone, or how to not
以及何时该倾听那些孤独感，何时该去建立联系并与他人计划活动。出于许多原因，我希望你会觉得这期节目非常有用。Francesca非常值得倾听和交流，我们的谈话让我感到非常振奋。希望你也有同感。期待在节目后与你交流。我想欢迎今天的嘉宾Francesca Spector。你好，Francesca。你好，Marianne。你是一位记者，也是我们稍后要谈论的那本书的作者。但你的专长，或者说因为某种原因成为了你的专长，是关于如何独处，或者如何不
be part of a couple or a relationship and how to do it well. Is that right? You know, it's so funny because it can be interpreted in so many different ways. I think the word alone, a lot of people still see it as synonymous with single. And the fact is, I think because I've been predominantly single for most of the past four years since I started writing about this subject, people are naturally making that conflation. I guess the way that I like to think about it is the ideas of alonement about how to spend time alone healthily and how to balance that with our natural desire for social time as well I think that being single can be a really fertile ground to explore that it's not the only life situation as we'll talk about in this podcast but one of those situations where it becomes a really good area to explore one's natural tolerance for time alone and how to make that a bit better and a bit more enjoyable so yeah it's it's really it is very open to interpretation and for a lot of people that's
处于一段关系中，并且如何过好这种生活。是这样吗？这很有趣，因为它可以有多种解读。我认为“alone”（独处）这个词，很多人仍然将其与“single”（单身）划等号。事实上，我认为因为我在过去四年里，也就是我开始写这个主题以来，大部分时间都是单身，所以人们自然而然地产生了这种混淆。我想我喜欢的方式是把“Alonement”看作是关于如何健康地度过独处时光，以及如何将其与我们对社交时间的自然需求相平衡。我认为单身可以是一个探索这一点的肥沃土壤，虽然正如我们将在播客中讨论的那样，这并不是唯一的生活状态，但它确实是一个探索个人对独处时间的耐受力，以及如何让独处变得更好、更愉快的好领域。所以，是的，它确实非常开放，可以有多种解读，对很多人来说，这就是
when they discover my book and my podcast and my platform when they are in a period of being single yeah absolutely and one of the reasons I wanted to invite you on we've worked quite a lot together in terms of guest expert for your journalism pieces which I've loved being part of so thank you for that thank you it's been so lovely working with you thank you you're welcome one of the reasons I wanted to bring you on is because psychology can be what feels like quite a solo pursuit because it's it's you and your career and you're having to make decisions that might be in isolation of those around you. And in fact, one of the decisions I made was sort of to
他们发现我的书、播客和平台的时候，也就是他们处于单身时期的时候。是的，绝对是。我邀请你来的原因之一是，我们合作过很多次，你作为我新闻稿件的客座专家，我很喜欢参与其中，谢谢你。谢谢，和你一起工作非常愉快。不客气。我邀请你来的原因之一是，心理学有时感觉像是一项孤独的追求，因为这是你和你的职业，你必须做出可能与周围人隔绝的决定。事实上，我做出的决定之一就是
decide to split up a relationship because I wanted, I knew where I was going and I knew it would involve me having to find new routes and new connections and trying to make my own way. But it means that quite often people are restarting or starting a new chapter of their life, and they're doing it in a way that feels like they might be quite isolated or sometimes even they're having to move to the other end of the country, either for a job offer or for a course offer. And it might mean either not living with their family or commuting back to their family or just just even if you are moving with your family trying to start over again
决定结束一段关系，因为我知道我要去哪里，我知道这需要我寻找新的路径和联系，并尝试走出自己的路。但这意味着人们经常在重启或开启人生的新篇章，而且他们这样做的方式感觉像是相当孤立，有时甚至不得不搬到国家的另一端，无论是为了工作机会还是课程录取。这可能意味着不与家人住在一起，或者需要通勤回家人身边，或者即使你是和家人一起搬迁，也要尝试重新开始。
it's really really complicated it is and I think there are so many things worth doing in life there are so many things that are the most probably in the most self-actualizing things that you might do, whether that's being able to travel or live abroad for a period or pursuing something like psychology as a profession. A lot of those things, they require overcoming some sort of fear of being alone. And I don't think we really speak enough about how often that fear even whether you know whether it's named or not is the thing that actually stops people from pursuing their dreams and then people you know and then further down the line you know 10-20 years it's like oh I never did this because of so and so and I think that that resentment's probably loaded in the wrong place I think the first thing to tackle is, right, why is being alone so scary to begin with? Absolutely. And I guess I'm thinking
这真的非常复杂。确实如此，我认为生活中有很多值得做的事情，有很多最能实现自我价值的事情，无论是去旅行、在国外生活一段时间，还是追求心理学这样的职业。很多这些事情都需要克服某种对独处的恐惧。我不认为我们谈论得足够多，关于这种恐惧——无论它是否被命名——往往就是阻止人们追求梦想的原因。然后人们在多年后，比如10到20年后，会说“我因为某某原因从未做过这件事”，我认为这种怨恨可能放错了地方。我认为首先要解决的是：为什么独处一开始就这么可怕？绝对是。我想
about how, especially over the last few years, we've all become not at all tolerant to the idea of being bored. And, you know, we've all become pretty ADHDhd about our phones you know and it's like it's thought that it's as addictive as crack isn't it having a smartphone um and you know someone was talking um the other day about being on a being on a train for three hours and they observed this older chap who just peacefully sat and watched you, the scenery unfold for those three hours, because he didn't either didn't have a mobile or didn't choose to use it. And in contrast to the people that were speaking, they were on their phones, they had their tablets, they had, you know, music to listen to. It was like they couldn't bear to have that unstructured time of being
关于这一点，尤其是过去几年，我们所有人都变得完全无法忍受无聊。你知道，我们对手机变得非常“多动症”，有人说智能手机像毒品一样让人上瘾。有人前几天谈到在火车上坐了三个小时，观察到一位老先生，他只是平静地坐着，看着窗外的风景流逝，因为他要么没有手机，要么选择不用。相比之下，那些正在说话的人，他们拿着手机、平板电脑，听着音乐。感觉他们无法忍受那种没有结构的独处时间，
just alone, they had to be part of something how how's your take on that yeah well firstly I don't know how much I believe in the idea of boredom I know it sound like a sort of you know parents sort of saying this to a child um you know sort of complaining about being bored but I just think there are so many things that we have this wealth of information, entertainment online and everywhere else. You know, we have, I'm sounding really old here. You know, we have public libraries. We have, the whole world is very, very stimulating
他们必须成为某种事物的一部分。你对此有什么看法？是的，首先，我不知道我有多相信“无聊”这个概念。我知道这听起来像父母对孩子说的话，抱怨无聊，但我只是认为我们拥有如此丰富的信息和在线娱乐资源。你知道，我听起来真的很老派。我们有公共图书馆。当我们有机会体验时，整个世界是非常、非常刺激和令人兴奋的。
and exciting when we have the chance to experience it. And I think the problem is we've normalized a level of as you say a level of noise which is so distracting without allowing us to go into any depth and I think I think it's crazy that our you know our attention spans are sort of evolving into a TikTok length um period of time it. It's really crazy. And, you know, I definitely can speak from my own experience. When I find myself feeling the most lonely, I'll be going on Instagram the most, but then inexplicably, like ignoring all the WhatsApps from my close friends or not feeling like I have time to reply to a voice note but scrolling for hours and hours and I think it's that sense of I don't know it's like a sense of sort of calm and like
我认为问题在于我们已经习惯了一种你所说的噪音水平，这种噪音非常分散注意力，却不允许我们进行任何深入的思考。我认为我们的注意力跨度正在演变成TikTok长度的时间，这真的很疯狂。而且，我绝对可以从我自己的经验中说，当我感到最孤独的时候，我反而会更多地刷Instagram，但却莫名其妙地忽略了亲密朋友的所有WhatsApp消息，或者觉得没时间回复语音信息，却刷了几个小时。我认为这是一种……我不知道，这是一种平静和
groundedness you need to get to to be able to actually find this stuff engaging in a way that feels nourishing not just sort of distracting to the point that, like, you know, it's actually more like a crutch. But I think that that's, it's why that I say that with, with alonement, with, you know, which, which alonement just in and of itself just means kind of time alone that's positive and fulfilling and nourishing the opposite to loneliness but I think to get to the state of alone month the sounds very that sounds very enlightened doesn't it but you know just to get to any positive alone time space you need to have a grounding practice like something like breath work meditation doesn't have to be as you know it doesn't have to sound as lofty as that you know walking it doesn't have to sound as lofty as that, you know, walking by yourself, reading, whatever.
扎根感，你需要达到这种状态，才能真正发现这些东西以一种滋养的方式吸引你，而不是仅仅分散注意力，以至于它更像是一种拐杖。但我认为，这就是为什么我说“Alonement”——它本身就意味着一种积极、充实和滋养的独处时间，与孤独相反。但我认为要达到“Alonement”的状态——这听起来很开明，不是吗？但仅仅是为了获得任何积极的独处空间，你需要一种扎根练习，比如呼吸法、冥想——它不必听起来那么高深，比如独自散步、阅读等等。
Something that will take you away from that frenetic, distracted state to a bit more of a sort of slow exhaling state that then you can enjoy things a bit more and actually be a bit more comfortable in your own company to then be able to sort of think about the bigger periods of time you might spend by yourself. Yeah, yeah yeah absolutely and and I guess it's thinking about how you want to be alone isn't it so alone isn't the same as lonely and if you feel lonely it's perhaps a sign that you can do things differently yeah absolutely I mean I think it's worth saying like you can feel alone months and you can feel loneliness in the same day hell you can probably feel them in the same hour it's you know it's really I think it's funny because when I started out um mostly what I spoke about was almost you know how, how to make your alone time better. So, you know, how to plan in solo dates into your schedule, how to actually, you know, think proactively about what you're doing. All of that, you know, a little bit like also crossing over with the self-care but actually as my thinking has evolved as I've had more conversations about
一些能让你从那种狂热、分心的状态中解脱出来，进入一种更缓慢、更放松的状态，这样你就能更好地享受事物，在自己的陪伴下感到更自在，从而去思考你可能独自度过的更长的时间。是的，绝对是。我想这在于思考你想要如何独处，对吧？所以“独处”并不等同于“孤独”，如果你感到孤独，这可能是一个信号，说明你可以换种方式做事。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，我认为值得一提的是，你可以在同一天感受到“Alonement”和孤独，甚至可以在同一个小时内感受到它们。这真的很有趣，因为当我刚开始时，
this spoken to more experts I think a lot more of that is in the balance and acknowledging that for instance you know I come to this as from the perspective of a natural extrovert and I you know I say natural because I think that there is you know scientific um evidence you'll know more about this than me that you know you know genetically you are wired one way or the other towards extroversion or introversion I am more wired towards extroversion so I know that actually a big important thing for me safeguarding against loneliness is sort of planning ahead my week and thinking okay like how much time am I going to have with others this week how many how much quality time time how am I going to get that into my day whether that's the
我主要谈论的是如何让你的独处时间变得更好。比如，如何将个人约会安排进你的日程，如何主动思考你在做什么。所有这些，有点像自我关怀的交叉，但随着我的思考演变，随着我与更多专家进行对话，
yoga class I'm doing at lunchtime or whether that's you know meeting up with a friend going and sitting on someone's sofa one evening and I think it's really just being aware that both of those can happen and not sort of almost, I don't know, not being so self-critical about those times where you are sitting alone on a train and you feel the need to pick up your phone, just I'm not in this sort of frenetic state of not really appreciating my alone time in the nourishing way that I should or would want to. Absolutely it's giving yourself permission to just enjoy that moment and open up that book perhaps and not feel guilty about that and not worry about what other people might be thinking or saying right because I mean that's another element that comes into it I think that quite often even if we're alone at home it's really funny it's like the sort of we're almost imagining what people might be saying especially I think trigger times like a Saturday night or New Year's Eve is the big one um even though I don't know about you I've
我认为这更多在于平衡，并承认例如，我从一个天生的外向者角度来看待这个问题。我说是“天生”，是因为我认为有科学证据——你比我更了解这一点——即在基因上，你天生倾向于外向或内向。我更倾向于外向，所以我知道，对我来说，防止孤独的一个重要事情是提前规划我的一周，思考：这周我将有多少时间和别人在一起？我将如何把高质量的时间安排进我的一天？无论是午餐时间的瑜伽课，还是和朋友见面，或者某天晚上去某人的沙发上坐坐。我认为这只是意识到这两者都可以发生，而不是对自己坐在火车上感到孤独、觉得需要拿起手机的那些时刻进行自我批评，我只是没有处于那种以滋养方式欣赏独处时间的狂热状态。绝对是，这是给自己许可去享受那一刻，打开那本书，而不为此感到内疚，也不担心别人在想什么或说什么。因为我认为这是另一个因素，即使我们独自在家，也很有趣，我们几乎在想象别人可能会说什么，尤其是在触发时刻，比如周六晚上或除夕夜。虽然我不知道你怎么样，但我
hated most New Year's Eves and I really want to spend it alone yeah it's just such it's such a thing it's such a universal thing and everyone drags themselves out and I just yeah we sort of imagine that and I think that actually the more we normalize conversations about this and we always the more we open it up and make it a bit sociable. Like, oh, I just had a really great train journey, read a book, you know, stared out the window, and then someone's like, oh, that sounds good, I might do that. You know, we're social beings in a lot of ways,
讨厌大多数除夕夜，我真的想独自度过。是的，这真是一件普遍的事情，每个人都把自己拖出去，我只是……我们想象那样，我认为实际上我们越是让关于这个话题的对话正常化，我们就越能让它变得更社交化。比如，“我刚才经历了一次很棒的火车旅行，读了一本书，盯着窗外看”，然后有人说，“哦，听起来不错，我也许会那样做。”我们从很多方面来说都是社会性动物，
and I think that actually normalising aloneness for each other can be quite a healthy thing to do as well. So you almost, then the next time you're sitting there alone on a train we're using that um example you know even alone on a Saturday night you're kind of thinking oh like you know I don't know Emma did this whoever Emma is but you know Emma did this last Saturday and she had a great time like maybe you know we can chat about this we can relate about this this is not a weird state of being this is actually something I need as much as much as I need my you know Friday happy hour drinks whatever absolutely absolutely let's normalize
我认为让彼此的独处正常化也是一件健康的事情。所以，下次你独自坐在火车上时，我们用那个例子，甚至在周六晚上独自一人时，你也会想，“哦，Emma做了这个，不管Emma是谁，但她上周六做了这个，她玩得很开心。”也许我们可以聊聊这个，我们可以产生共鸣，这不是一种奇怪的存在状态，这实际上是我像需要周五欢乐时光的饮品一样需要的东西。绝对是，让我们把“Alonement”正常化吧。
alonement for sure and at this time of year people who are getting on to doctorate courses in psychology are sometimes having to decide whether potentially to accept a place that means that come September, they will be moving possibly hours away from everything they currently know. What would be your advice about how to navigate that period well I mean so assuming assuming this person makes the decision to to then go I think that it is it is a very difficult decision um to begin with I think that we are so we're told from god we're told from like you know first years of primary school you know we're taught social skills we're taught how to be around others um you know we're taught rightfully obviously the you know the the importance of friends family but we're not taught solitude skills and so we're not taught the skills to deal with a scenario like that where you're like oh wow i really am away
在每年的这个时候，那些进入心理学博士课程的人有时不得不决定是否接受一个意味着到了九月，他们将搬到离目前所知的一切几小时路程之外的地方。关于如何顺利度过那个时期，你有什么建议？我的意思是，假设这个人决定去，我认为这是一个非常艰难的决定。首先，我认为我们从小学一年级开始就被教导社交技能，被教导如何与他人相处，被教导朋友和家人的重要性，但我们没有被教导“独处技能”。所以我们没有被教导如何处理那种你发现自己远离
from my support system no one ever gave you know yeah okay we're told to told to be ambitious we're told to pursue our dreams but actually no one gave me the skill set to be able to navigate this scenario so I think even just beginning if that feels like a daunting decision that you've made starting with okay that is that is hard and you know so socially we're not really equipped to do that um you know to begin with it is it is it is natural to feel scared but then I think that there is so often I think people will say that they've come to a state of I don't know increased alone time whether that's through a breakup whether that's through living alone for the first time whether that's through I don't know a pandemic you know
支持系统的场景。没有人教过我们。是的，我们被教导要雄心勃勃，被教导要追求梦想，但实际上没有人给我一套技能来应对这种情况。所以我认为，即使这感觉是一个令人生畏的决定，从承认“这很难”开始，而且在社会上我们并没有真正准备好这样做。一开始感到害怕是很自然的。但我认为，人们经常说他们已经达到了一种增加独处时间的状态，无论是通过分手、第一次独自生活，还是通过最近历史上的大流行，他们有了那种时间，这可以是一个了解自己的富有成效的时期。这可能非常令人兴奋，我认为知道这一点可能是内在的，只是更主动地思考，比如，“好吧，我以前的日程安排可能是由去参加朋友们都参加的陶艺课决定的，即使我并不真的喜欢陶艺，或者我做着我朋友圈或家人想做的一切，但这并不一定是我想要的生活方式。”仅仅思考这种“空白画布”——虽然空白画布很可怕，但也是一个令人兴奋的、肥沃的前景。我认为这总是一个
in recent history where they've had that time and it can be a really fruitful time to learn a bit more about yourself it can be really exciting and I think that knowing that that might be inherent too and just I guess thinking a bit more proactively about you know okay so my schedule back home or back where I'm coming from might have been dictated by you know maybe going to the I don't know you know going to the pottery class that all my friends do even though I'm not really that into pottery or like I'm doing everything that my immediate friendship group or you know family kind of fancy doing but that's not something that necessarily is how I would live my life and just thinking about this kind of um blank canvas is okay scary because blank canvases are scary but also an exciting fertile prospect you know I think that that is it always is an
机会，即使我们在社会中没有这样定义它。而且，正如我所说的关于平衡，我认为有些人是天生的内向者。老实说，我有一个表弟，他在自己的陪伴下非常棒，他很有趣，因为他超级自信，是每个派对的灵魂人物，但他喜欢大流行，他真的把它当作一个巨大的机会去沉浸在看他喜欢的电影、进行长距离散步中。如果你像我一样，更倾向于外向，并且你认为“好吧，我真的会很挣扎，因为这只是
opportunity even though we don't frame it that way um in society and but you know I think also what I said about balance as well I think that so you know some people are natural introverts and honestly I've had you know my cousin for instance he is amazing in his own company he's funny because he's super confident super you know life of every party but loved the pandemic and he really took that as a huge opportunity to just lean into all the you know watching all the films he likes taking really long walks if you are if you are wired a little bit more like me um and you are more towards the extra version and you think okay I'm really going to struggle because this is just
我自然需要的”，我认为这真的需要回到原点，思考：“好吧，我想独自做这些美好的事情，我想充分利用我的时间，但我也确实需要每周见人三次，无论是什么。”我们都有不同的平衡，或者我确实需要每周至少一两次社区活动。思考那可能是什么，并在你所拥有的可能性范围内更主动一点。把它当作一个逻辑问题来思考，因为当你感到有点孤独时，很容易把它看作是一个非常个人、非常孤立的状态，没有人经历过。
naturally what I need I think it's really going back to square one and thinking okay so I want to do these nice things alone I want to make the best thing best of my time but like also I do need you know I do need to see someone three evenings a week whatever like we all have different sort of balances or I do need maybe I don't know a community activity at least once or twice a week and thinking what that might be and just being a bit more proactive within the obviously it depends where you are but within the realms of what you have possible like thinking about this as like almost a logic problem because I think it's so easy easy to think about to feel when you feel a bit lonely and when you leave it too long to to think about this as a sort of very personal very isolated state that no one ever has
而如果你能更主动、更客观地思考它——虽然说起来容易做起来难——但几乎是预见这些问题，那么这可以成为一个很好的状态，去建立你需要的框架，从而能够同时享受社交时间和独处时间。绝对是。当你说话时，我在想，天哪，如果我在做临床心理学实习生时有这种替代叙事就好了。因为我确实在第一年的很多周末都回到了父母住的地方，见见住在附近的朋友。是的，我有
experienced whereas if you can think about it a bit more proactively a bit more detachedly and you know obviously easier said than done but like almost anticipating these issues then that can be a really good state to then just put in the framework that you need to be able to enjoy social time and solitude time alongside each other absolutely and as you talk I'm thinking gosh I wish I'd had this alternative narrative available to me when it was my time to be a trainee clinical psychologist actually because I spent many of my weekends certainly in the first year coming back you know an hour to where my parents lived and seeing my friends that lived more locally and yes I've got
一些非常美好的回忆，比如去参加我正常的周六早晨普拉提课，然后和朋友叙旧，喝杯茶，花时间在一起。这意味着我能见到我的父母——我父亲现在去世了，所以这很美好。但如果我当时有这种想法，我可以独自一人，或者参加当地的课程学习一些东西，与周围的人建立更多联系，忍受结识新朋友、建立新联系，而不是仅仅把旧朋友当作拐杖。我不知道那会是什么样子。这很难。而且我认为，当你确实有那种来自家乡的朋友和家人的牵挂时，这很困难。
some I had some really fond memories of um you know going to my normal Saturday morning Pilates class and then catching up with my friend and having um a cup of tea together and you know, going to my normal Saturday morning Pilates class and then catching up with my friend and having a cup of tea together and, you know, spending time together. And it meant that I got to see my dad and my mum or my dad's passed away now. So it's kind of, you know, it's nice. But if I'd had the idea that I could just be by myself or, you know, join a local class and learn something, connect more to the people around me, you know, bear to tolerate meeting new people, making new connections, rather than just leaning as a crutch on my old ones. You know, I don't know what that would have been like. It's hard. And I think, you know, it's difficult where you do have that, you know, that pull of, you know, friends and family back home.
这是一种非常正常的应对机制，就是经常回去。但我认为这当然是因人而异的。这让我想起了我在大学的第一年，我经常回家，这意味着我不认为我交到了任何朋友。实际上，我交到了两个大学朋友，非常亲密的朋友，这很好，因为成年后你真的需要多少朋友呢？只要有高质量的就够了。但我确实有点后悔没有那种大学经历，因为我一直在来回奔波。
And it is, you know, that's one really normal coping mechanism to be going back a lot. But, you know, I suppose it's obviously like case by case basis but like I think almost being able to sort of I don't know I I I was the same like it's actually making me think of my first year at university um I I was going home quite a lot um and it means I don't think I ever made any I've made two friends from university, actually, two very close friends, which is great because, you know, how many friends do you need in adulthood, really, you know, as long as you've got the quality ones. But I do sort of regret not having that university experience because I was going back and forth all the time.
我特别希望，我在利兹大学读本科时，我没有去走约克郡荒原。我知道这听起来很荒谬，但我可能不会再回去走约克郡荒原了，但我真的很希望我当时能庆祝我所在的地方。我认为在别处生活一段时间的机会真的很令人兴奋，我真的很希望我当时能与环境建立更多联系。即使我不知道，如果你知道你有一群坚实的朋友可以回去，而且你知道你不一定非要在这个地方交到一辈子的朋友，我认为即使从“我在这当地想做什么？”开始，因为也许因为它在当地，有这些
And I wish, like specifically, I'm thinking about, I was at university in Leeds for my undergrad and I'm like I didn't go and walk the Yorkshire Moors like I know it sounds like a ridiculous thing to be but I'm probably not going back to walk the Yorkshire Moors but I really wish I'd sort of got I'd celebrated where I was I think the chance to live somewhere else uh for a bit is really exciting and I really wish I'd sort of connected with the environment a bit more and even I don't know I think that if you know you've got your solid ground of people to come back to and you know that it's not necessarily like you need to make your friends for life in this place I think even leading with like okay what do I want to do in this local area you know because it's maybe because it's local and it's got these
特定的东西，或者我想尝试什么样的身份？从这一点出发。然后要么你会遇到那里的人，如果你去参加课程或运动，或者你可以对别人说，
specific things or what do I want to like what kind of identities do I want to do in this local area? You know, because it's maybe because it's local and it's got these specific things or what do I want to like, what kind of identities do I want to try on for a bit? Leading with that. And then either you'll meet people there, you know, if you're going to a class or something or, you know, an exercise or whatever, or you can say to people,
“哦，我要去，你想和我一起去吗？”显然这很大胆，但实际上效果很好。我发现，去年年底到今年年初我在利兹住了四个月，我发现外籍人士有一个非常美妙的地方，那就是他们非常习惯于在这些情况下可能产生的孤独感，所以他们能够做到这一点。这就像非常酷的美国式做法，“哦，是的，我要去海滩，欢迎加入。”人们会跟随，因为我们在这个生活中有多主动？我们有多少次在等待别人的引导？所以我认为，即使这不是为了
oh, like I'm going, do you want to come with me? And obviously that's a really bold thing to do, but actually it works quite well. I find like I've been, I was living in Lis for um four months at the end of last year coming into this one and I found a really wonderful thing about um about expats is that they're so used to the potential for loneliness in situations that they're they're able to do that it's like quite cool American things but oh yeah I'm going to the beach welcome to come people follow because like how often are we proactive in this life how often do we actually wait more often for the lead of other people so I think you know even if it's not a case of
替换家乡的朋友和家人，那片肥沃的空间也可以是关于“做你自己”一段时间，看看谁可能会跟随，谁不会。有趣的是你提到了美国人。2003年，我和朋友环球背包旅行了六个月，我们在圣地亚哥，她病得很重，不得不躺在床上休息。她说：“真的，不要只是看着我生病，我会没事的，我只需要休息，我需要睡觉。”房间也很小，你可能会想，“也许这是我离开的时候了。”她说：“你出去吧，我一会儿见你。”我说：“好吧。”所以我去了电影院。我甚至不记得我看了什么，
needing to replace friends and family back home that can be a really again that that fertile space can be something about just you know doing you for a bit and seeing who might follow and who might not it's funny you mention Americans there um in 2003 I was backpacking around the world with my friend for six months and we found ourselves in San Diego um and she got very very unwell just had to lay in bed for a bit and she was like seriously don't just don't just watch me be unwell I'm gonna be okay I just need to rest I need to sleep yeah and there's tiny rooms as well you're probably like okay maybe maybe there's my time to leave oh yeah she's like you just you go out and I'll see you in a bit um I was like okay so I went to the cinema um I can't even remember what I saw um
但我独自坐在电影院里，这实际上是独自做的完美活动，因为无论如何你在表演期间都不应该说话。我前面坐着一个美国小伙子，他看起来和他的女朋友在一起，他说：“哦，嗨，你想过来和我们一起坐吗？”我说：“不，不，我很好。”他说：“哦，我叫Brian。”我说：“哦，嗨，Brian，不，我很好。”我们最终聊了起来。然后他说，在表演结束时，
but I was I was sitting in the cinema by myself which is actually the perfect activity to do by yourself because you're not supposed to speak during during performances anyway um and there's a chap on the on the just in front of me who's American and he was with what looked like his girlfriend and he was like oh hi like do you want to come sit with us and I was like no no no I'm okay and uh he said oh my my name's Brian and I was like oh hi Brian no, no, I'm okay. I'm all right. And he said, oh, my name's Brian. And I was like, oh, hi, Brian. And we sort of ended up chatting. And then he said, oh, at the end of the performance,
他说：“我知道这真的很……我现在要放下美国口音了，但这真的很直接，很奇怪，但你明天想和我一起出去吃晚饭吗？我很喜欢你。”我说：“我很抱歉，Brian，我很想，但我明天要去墨西哥。”这是最好的拒绝。但我经常想，如果我和Brian出去吃晚饭会发生什么。谁知道呢，Brian
the end of the show, he said, I know this is really, I'm going to drop the American accent now, but this is really forward and really weird, but did you want to come out for dinner with me tomorrow? I really like you. And I was like, I'm really'm really sorry Brian I would love to but I'm going to Mexico tomorrow it's like the best the best to know but I often wonder what would have happened you know if I'd gone out to dinner with Brian like who knows was Brian
有吸引力吗？他不难看。是的，他不难看。但几乎我很高兴我不必去，因为你知道，我认为他只是更擅长创造机会，寻求这些机会，并且相当活在当下。是的，我认为绝对有一种美国式的自信，我们不一定有。但这说起来容易。但是，我在巴黎和最近的佛罗伦萨有过独自旅行，老实说，我遇到的人太多了。我认为如果你独自一人，我不知道你是否经历过，当你和一个朋友或伴侣去参加派对，而他们不是特别外向的人，你
attractive he wasn't unattractive yeah he wasn't unattractive but yeah yeah it's like almost I was partly was pleased I didn't have to go because like you know but you know I think just clearly he was better at yeah creating opportunities and seeking those and being quite in the moment I guess yeah yeah um I think definitely there's an American confidence confidence there that we don't necessarily have. But then it's so easy to say. But, you know, I've had solo trips in Paris and more recently Florence where, honestly, I've met too many people. And I think that there's something about if you're, you know, if you're by yourself I don't know if you've ever had that where you've gone to a friend with sorry gone to a party with a friend that you or you know with a partner where you're you're just they're not particularly they're not particularly outward facing person and you
最终陷入一种奇怪的情况，你们俩在一起，实际上没有遇到其他人，因为你们作为一个整体出现。当你独自在世界上移动时，事情会以一种你意想不到的方式发生，因为人们确实觉得他们可以走过来，邀请你和他们一起吃晚饭。这很有争议，我认为在电影院这样做很奇怪，但你会遇到这些偶然的机会。我认为我们低估了如果我们没有经历过独自背包旅行，这种情况会发生多少。
end up sort of in this weird thing where you are the pair of you and you don't actually meet people it's harder to meet people because you sort of come as a two when you're by yourself in the world like moving around things happen in a way that you know I think we talk you know there's this whole social media narrative around main character syndrome but like you sort of you are the main character and you do have adventures in a way that you just don't expect because people do feel like they can kind of come up and you know ask you to join them for dinner which you know is polarizing I think definitely at the cinema that's a very strange thing to do but you you have these stumble upon occasions and I think we sort of underestimate how much that might happen if we haven't actually been in the
绝对是，我喜欢和陌生人随意聊天。大流行期间我错过的一件事就是关于在Asda或Tesco买花椰菜之类的对话，因为陌生人停止了交谈。我认为戴着口罩和恐惧，我们没有以同样的方式这样做。我喜欢和路上遇到的随机的人聊天，传播一点快乐，在度过一天时了解一点陌生人。我真的很喜欢那样，但不是每个人都喜欢。我知道这也许也是我“Alonement”光谱的一部分。但你能告诉我们一点关于你那本精彩的书吗？我知道它是2021年《泰晤士报》的年度图书之一，对吧？是的，非常荣幸。
experience of being you know backpacking solo or whatever absolutely and I love a random chat to somebody like one of the things I missed during the pandemic was all the conversations about, you know, cauliflowers and things in Asda or Tesco because strangers just stopped speaking to each other. I think with the mask and with the fear, we just didn't do it in the same way. And I just love chatting to random people that you meet along the way and spreading a little bit of joy and learning a bit about strangers as you go about your day I really like that um but not everybody likes that I know it's perhaps part of my alonement spectrum as well but um could you tell us a little bit about your wonderful book please I know that it was the time one of the times books of the year in 2021 wasn't it yeah very very um yeah very flattered when that
它在2021年11月出版。所以，“Alonement”很有趣，因为人们理所当然地认为这是我在大流行期间提出的概念，但实际上它源于2018年底发生的一次分手。我和一个男人分手了，他非常完美，我以为我会嫁给他，但当我们到达那个终点线阶段时，很明显那可能不会发生。所以我不得不面对这条我完全没预料到的不同道路。我独自生活，我们曾计划住在一起，很多事情都在改变。在这个过程中，我发现这非常困难。而且因为
came out in November 2021 um so yeah it's so alone month is really funny because people quite rightly assume that um it was a something I came out with in the pandemic that that concept was born but actually it it came out of a breakup um in which happened at the end of 2018 so I'd well I'd broken up with a man who was you know perfectly wonderful but and you know who I thought I would marry but it became quite clear as we got to that sort of you know finish line stage that actually that probably wasn't going to be the case for us so I had to confront this whole different this whole path that I just wasn't expecting to and and I was living alone and I I you know we'd been planning to move in together a lot of things were changing and in that process I was finding it I was finding it very hard and also because
当时我周围很多朋友都订婚了，和伴侣住在一起。在这个人生阶段，我感到非常孤独。我意识到我害怕独自度过时光。我说：“哇，这真的激励了我。”这就是那个让我留在一段并不太顺利的关系中的恐惧，这就是那个让我周日晚上不断刷约会软件的东西，这就是那个让我依赖并不适合我的友谊或联系的东西。我说：“我不想被这种恐惧所支配。”
um I was at a time where a lot of my friends were getting engaged and were living with partners. And I felt very kind of alone in this life stage. And I realized that I had this fear of spending time by myself. And I was like, wow, this is, this is really, this has really motivated me. This, you know, this, this was the thing that, this was the fear that kept me in that relationship that wasn't quite working out this is the thing that keeps apparently you know sending me into scrolling dating apps on Sunday nights this is the thing that's making me um I don't lean on friendships or connections that aren't quite working for me and I was like I don't I don't want to be dictated by this fear
我想解决它。所以我花了一年左右的时间——在大流行前发生这件事真是太搞笑了——学习在自己的陪伴下舒适地独处，写博客，写关于这个主题的东西，但也只是在非常私人的层面上做这件事。我到了那个点，
you know I'd rather sort it out. And so I spent about a year, hilarious that this happened pre-pandemic, but about a year learning to be comfortably alone in my own company and sort of blogging and, you know, writing about that, but also just doing it on a sort of very private level. And I came to the point where,
我想我和很多人谈过这件事，我和很多人进行了这种对话，他们不仅仅是在说“是是是”，他们也在说“哇，我们有共鸣”。与此同时，我开始了一个关于这个主题的播客，我说：“哇，我认为这需要成为一本书。”令人惊讶的是，这本手册当时并不存在。我希望它能为任何再次经历这一切的我提供帮助。所以，这就是我开始的地方。
I think I'd spoken about it with so many people and I'd I don't know I'd I'd had this conversation with so many people where it did feel like they weren't just saying yeah yeah yeah they were also saying wow we we relate um and I'd actually in the meantime started a podcast around that and I was like wow I think that this needs to be this needs to be a book. It's amazing that this manual wasn't there for me. And I kind of would want it to be there for any version of me going through this again. So anyway, so that was where I started.
我想我已经和很多人谈论过这件事了，我不知道，我和很多人进行过这样的对话，他们不仅仅是在敷衍我，他们也说，哇，我们感同身受。与此同时，我实际上围绕这个话题开了一个播客，当时我就想，哇，我觉得这应该成为一本书。令人惊讶的是，我当时竟然没有这本指南。我希望任何经历过这一切的“我”都能拥有它。总之，这就是我开始创作的初衷。
I think I began with honestly just coining the word alone month. So I was like, right, okay, I need to have a shorthand for when I say to people, I spent, you know, I spent a week, a weekend evening alone and they don't say, oh, like, oh, poor you. You know, it's not a situation of pity, it's one of triumph.
我想我最初只是单纯地创造了“独处月”（alonement）这个词。当时我就想，好吧，我需要一个简短的词，当我告诉别人我独自度过了一个周末晚上时，他们不会说“哦，真可怜”。你知道，这不是一种值得同情的情况，而是一种胜利。
And I started exploring things like, for instance, the work of Dr. Virginia Thomas. She's a researcher in the US. She specializes in something called solitude skills. So learning skills to be comfortably alone, like a lot of the stuff I've touched upon in this episode. So learning to balance social time and solitude and learning to sort of schedule ahead alone time into your calendar
我开始探索一些东西，比如弗吉尼亚·托马斯博士（Dr. Virginia Thomas）的研究。她是美国的一位研究员，专门研究所谓的“独处技能”。也就是学习如何舒适地独处，就像我在这一集中提到的很多内容一样。比如学习平衡社交时间和独处时间，学习如何提前在日程表中安排独处时间。
learning to communicate to others when you need healthy alone time learning to emotionally regulate so doing things like meditation journaling get into that grounded state where you can enjoy other states of alone time without I don't know panicking panicking so much it's it's intolerable um and and all that stuff was was what ended up going into the book um and then as I say so I had the podcast and I still have the podcast and I was having a lot of conversations with people like Alan de Botton the um author Paul Nabel uh former uh Vogue editor Alexandra Shulman, and getting lots of different perspectives from people at different life stages, different ages, different relationship statuses about how they had alone time in their own life, how it factored in, how they liked it, how they
学习如何向他人传达你需要健康的独处时间，学习如何进行情绪调节，比如通过冥想、写日记，让自己进入那种平和的状态，这样你就可以享受其他形式的独处，而不会感到恐慌，不会觉得难以忍受。所有这些内容最终都写进了书里。正如我所说，我当时有播客，现在也还有，我与艾伦·德波顿（Alain de Botton）等作家、前《Vogue》编辑亚历山德拉·舒尔曼（Alexandra Shulman）等人进行了很多对话，从不同人生阶段、不同年龄、不同关系状态的人那里获得了许多不同的视角，了解他们如何在自己的生活中安排独处时间，独处在他们生活中扮演了什么角色，他们如何看待独处，以及他们如何
didn't, how it had changed. And the book ended up as this sort of compilation of that so it was part memoir part my own reported experience part sort of expert interviews that I'd done through the podcast and done specifically for the book and part you know sort of research into these things so really just interesting studies like for instance one of them is something called the spotlight effect, which is a phenomenon, I think, discovered or at least coined by a researcher called Thomas Gilovich. And he discovered that actually when we're alone in a crowd, we overestimate how much other people are looking at us by quite some way and I think just having that having that research having that phenomenon in your head and knowing that when you're eating alone at a restaurant or something like that you really you think that you're sitting there being observed by everyone um but you're really not and and it's just it's a comforting thing um and also all of that came in together as this deep dive into alone time that has become this manual this
看待这种变化。这本书最终成为了这些内容的汇编，它既是回忆录，也是我个人的经历记录，还包含了我通过播客和专门为本书进行的专家访谈，以及对这些课题的研究。其中一些研究非常有趣，比如“聚光灯效应”（spotlight effect），这是一个由研究员托马斯·吉洛维奇（Thomas Gilovich）发现或至少是命名的现象。他发现，实际上当我们身处人群中时，我们会大大高估别人关注我们的程度。我认为，只要脑子里有这个研究、有这个现象，当你独自在餐厅吃饭时，你以为每个人都在盯着你看，但实际上并没有。这是一种令人宽慰的事情。所有这些汇集在一起，深入探讨了独处时间，并最终形成了这本手册，这本
handbook I think it's the accidental breakup manual that people seem to get handed by their their close friends when they go through a breakup um although as I say it's it's relevant to all uh and yeah that's that's uh and I guess in the uh wake of pandemic, or at least, I mean, it came out during the pandemic. It came out in March 2021. That took on a whole new resonance, both for people navigating more alone time than they'd ever been used to before. Or on the flip side, people who were, you know, I don't know, cramped into a one bed flat with their partner or, you know, in a house with their kids homeschooling experiencing alone time or a lack of it in a whole different way and and putting it on a pedestal in a way that they might not have before absolutely and well done for the work you're doing and you know I
手册，我想它就像是人们在经历分手时，亲密朋友会递给他们的“意外分手指南”。尽管正如我所说，它对所有人都有意义。是的，在疫情之后，或者说，它是在疫情期间出版的，2021年3月出版。这引起了全新的共鸣，无论是对于那些不得不面对比以往更多独处时间的人，还是对于那些被困在狭小公寓里与伴侣在一起，或者在家里一边照顾孩子一边居家办公的人来说，他们以一种全新的方式体验着独处或缺乏独处，并以一种前所未有的方式重视它。绝对是这样，你所做的工作非常出色，而且我知道
know that I wish it had been around you know know, earlier in my life. Because other than a four year relationship, I spent most of my adult life single, actually, and trying to feel confident enough to go out and eat dinner by yourself. I'm definitely there now. Now I've got children, but I'm married. But I still do really enjoy and enjoy mindfully sitting in a cafe eating by myself or having a drink and watching other people and just you know being part of something but enjoying that and knowing that that's that's okay um have you got any just before we finish have you got any tips or advice for, yeah, for how people can begin to tentatively explore alone-ment? Yeah, absolutely. So I would say baby steps. So, you know, the first thing is to be able to say, spend, I don't know, 10 minutes alone a day. Something that I do, I've done for, getting on for about two years now,
我真希望在我生命中更早的时候就有这本书。因为除了那段四年的感情，我成年后的大部分时间都是单身，我曾努力让自己有足够的自信去独自外出吃晚餐。我现在绝对做到了。虽然我现在结婚了，也有了孩子，但我仍然非常享受独自坐在咖啡馆里，有意识地享受用餐或喝杯饮料，观察其他人，成为环境的一部分，并享受这种感觉，知道这完全没问题。在我们结束之前，你有什么建议或技巧，可以帮助人们开始尝试探索“独处”吗？当然可以。我会说从小步开始。第一件事就是每天尝试独处10分钟。这是我一直在做的事情，大概已经坚持了两年了，
is I use the Calm app to do a 10 minute meditation every morning. And that just means that it's just this little thing I internalize that knows that I can sit and breathe with my eyes closed and I'm safe and that's okay. And it just, it's in the back of my mind as I go throughout my day. And honestly, I feel very strange if I haven't done it. So doing that or something like journaling in the afternoon and the evening, you know, getting your thoughts out on paper. And I think that's a really good exercise as well,
我每天早上都会用 Calm 应用程序进行10分钟的冥想。这意味着我内心深处知道，我可以闭上眼睛坐着呼吸，我是安全的，这没关系。这在我一天的生活中一直萦绕在心头。老实说，如果我没做这件事，我会觉得很奇怪。所以，做这件事，或者在下午和晚上写写日记，把你的想法写在纸上，我认为这也是一个非常好的练习，
because you start to listen to yourself a bit more you start to a take a bit more of a curiosity in your own interests needs thoughts whatever um and be just it's it's almost like I think it's it's allowed for me to sort of get my negative thoughts out as well and be aware of my inner critic a bit more I think just doing things like that which help you sort of meet yourself in a sort of non-threatening time limited way are really important to create that foundation and I think you know once you started practicing that a bit more and again you know things like you know things like going for walks without headphones can be really nice just on a lunch hour something like that once you're sort of practicing that a bit more I think you will naturally as I did you'll get a bit more curious to think you know how how far can I take this you know can I do those things where I don't
因为你开始更多地倾听自己，开始对自己的兴趣、需求、想法等产生更多的好奇心。而且，这几乎让我能够把负面想法释放出来，并更多地意识到我内心的批判者。我认为做这些事情，帮助你在一种无威胁、有时限的方式下与自己相遇，对于建立这种基础非常重要。一旦你开始更多地练习这些，比如在午休时间不戴耳机散步，一旦你开始更多地练习，我相信你会自然而然地像我一样，变得更好奇，想知道我能走多远，我可以做那些我以前
know if you maybe you see someone sitting in a cafe by themselves and you think oh I could never do that challenge yourself a bit you know it's a bit like exposure therapy go and have a coffee by yourself and and see how that is and you know it might a bit like exposure therapy go and have a coffee by yourself and and see how that is and you know it might be uncomfortable the first time uh or the second time obviously and do try and try to pick a place where you maybe you know you know the barista maybe or you know it's a nice environment with a comfortable chair or something like that way or a sofa where you can go and sit um and you'll find yourself going back and getting a bit bolder um and I think you know from there on it really does just it depends on you you know it
不知道的事情吗？比如你看到有人独自坐在咖啡馆里，你可能会想“我永远做不到”。挑战一下自己，这有点像暴露疗法，去独自喝杯咖啡，看看感觉如何。第一次或第二次可能会不舒服，这很正常。尽量选择一个你可能认识咖啡师的地方，或者环境舒适、有舒服椅子或沙发的地方。你会发现自己会不断尝试，变得越来越大胆。我认为从那以后，这真的取决于你自己，取决于
depends on how you know what your individual needs are you know say you're a film lover but you've never had the confidence to go to the cinema alone you might try that say you really love the sort of glamorous um notion of the solo diner you might experiment with that I think you know just going and exploring in different ways and also just opening the conversation up with your friends about doing this thing and normalizing it um I think that often you can have you know I've had people in my life where I'll think okay they're my sort of alignment icon at the moment like I want to be a bit more a bit more them a bit more bolder a bit bolder to do the things that they do alone and I think it just becomes a really wonderful process of exploration and yeah obviously
你的个人需求是什么。比如你是个电影爱好者，但从未有信心独自去电影院，你可以尝试一下。如果你真的很喜欢独自用餐那种迷人的概念，你可以尝试一下。我认为去以不同的方式探索，并与朋友们谈论这件事，让它变得正常化，是非常好的。在我的生活中，我会有一些人，我会想“他们是我目前的独处偶像”，我想变得更像他们一点，更勇敢一点，去独自做他们做的事情。我认为这变成了一个非常美妙的探索过程。当然，
you know I'm speaking as if we all have you know I'm speaking from the perspective of someone who is single lives alone freelance has quite a lot of freedom over my schedule at this life stage. But I think that alone time can also take on a whole different, it's like a commodity. It can take on a whole different sense of value in a stage where you have, you know, we have a partner, we have kids, where you have a close network of friends, you were sort of seeing each other all the time. And I think the consideration there, the thing to think about is also just proactively scheduling it in and thinking, okay, this needs, if this is something I'm valuing, like, I can schedule in, like, you know, an hour or two before I go and meet my friends on a Saturday, or I can, you know, schedule in this time, I can say to my partner, like, actually, this is something, you know, I quite fancy a Saturday or I can you know schedule in this time I can say to my partner like actually this is something you know I quite fancy a night in alone you know would it be okay
我说话的立场是一个单身、独居、自由职业者，在这个人生阶段对自己的时间安排有相当大的自由。但我认为，独处时间也可以呈现出完全不同的价值，就像一种商品。在你有伴侣、有孩子、有紧密的社交圈，经常见到彼此的阶段，独处时间具有完全不同的价值。我认为需要考虑的是主动安排它，并思考：如果这是我重视的事情，我可以安排在周六见朋友之前留出一两个小时，或者我可以安排这段时间，我可以对伴侣说：“其实，我挺想有一个独自待着的晚上，
if you looked after the kids this evening because I've got you know I quite like to experience like a movie alone or whatever I think it's all those communication things as well and feeling that alonement is a value that's important in and of it in and of itself enough to say it's it's like it's the same as saying I have a social plan you know it's making that time for you and valuing that enough to give that to yourself without feeling guilt around it because you know I think that the reassuring thing is the moment you start taking that time for yourself even if it's just you know 10 minutes a day or that choice evening every every couple of weeks it really comes back into your relationships with others and it really is a means to then give back more uh if you need
你今晚能帮忙照顾孩子吗？因为我想独自看部电影之类的。”我认为所有这些沟通都很重要，并且要感觉到“独处”本身就是一种重要的价值，足以让你说“这和我有一个社交计划是一样的”。这是为你自己留出时间，并足够重视它，从而给予自己这段时间，而不会感到内疚。因为我认为令人欣慰的是，当你开始为自己留出时间时，即使每天只有10分钟，或者每隔几周选择一个晚上，它真的会反哺你与他人的关系，如果你需要
to justify it that way no one should feel like they have to but it does seem to work out that way I love that and it sounds wonderfully liberating and empowering actually as a as a way of life and as a yeah just as a movement or yeah just giving yourself permission to do that it really is especially if you're someone that's told that you only exist in relation to other people you know someone that feels like a huge sense of um I don't know I think it's I think I think it is a gendered thing sometimes I think women particularly can feel like a sense of um sense of guilt if like you know they're taking that time for themselves and I think it's so it can feel very liberating once you do it realize you know
为它辩解的话，它确实是一种让你回馈更多的方式。没有人应该觉得他们必须辩解，但它确实是这样运作的。我喜欢这一点，这听起来非常令人解放和赋能，作为一种生活方式，或者仅仅作为一种运动，或者仅仅是给自己许可去这样做。这确实如此，特别是如果你是一个被告知你只存在于与他人的关系中，或者是一个感到巨大压力的人。我不知道，我认为这有时是一个性别问题。我认为女性尤其会感到一种内疚感，如果她们为自己留出时间。我认为一旦你做到了，意识到
it's not no one thinks you're a selfish so and so and actually it's it's made you a better person for yourself and others as a result yeah well I needed you and your work about 13 years before you before you started doing it but what I love is that it's there for people now um how can people learn more about you and your work francesca well so i uh i'm on social media as uh ches specter so c-h-e-z uh specter um on twitter and instagram uh and for the past uh seven months i've been writing a newsletter called the shoulds on substack so you can find that uh just francescaspector.substack.com and i post for uh for free and paid subscribers so i sign up to the to the mailing list and then that's the best way to keep in touch um weekly um with i do weekly newsletters and uh as my my
没有人会认为你是个自私的人，而且结果这让你对自己和他人来说都成为了一个更好的人。是的，我在你开始做这项工作之前的13年里就需要你和你的作品了。但我喜欢的是，现在它就在那里供人们使用。人们如何能更多地了解你和你的工作，弗朗西斯卡？我在社交媒体上是 @chezspecter，即 C-H-E-Z Specter，在 Twitter 和 Instagram 上。过去七个月里，我一直在 Substack 上写一份名为《The Shoulds》的时事通讯，你可以在 francescaspector.substack.com 找到它。我为免费和付费订阅者发布内容，所以注册邮件列表是保持联系的最佳方式，每周我都会发布时事通讯，
podcast season eight is coming out in the next couple of months so I'll be posting sort of bonus content and interviews and things on that so yeah lots lots coming out and of course your wonderful book too well yes I should really sorry I should really apologize to my publisher at that point yes and the book is also available everywhere um yeah bookshops uh amazon online all of those I will tag you um and pop all the details in the show notes for how people can reach you as well but thank you so much for your time I know this is going to be really really soul food for those that need to hear it at the moment and for for setting out in their new direction their new lives for either for a new job or for their new training doctoral courses so thank you so much for your time oh thank you wonderful to speak to you as ever marianne
我的播客第八季将在未来几个月内推出，所以我会在上面发布一些额外的内容、采访等。所以有很多内容即将推出。当然还有你那本精彩的书。是的，我真的应该向我的出版商道歉。是的，这本书在各处都有售，书店、亚马逊、在线平台等等。我会标记你，并在节目说明中附上所有关于如何联系你的详细信息。非常感谢你的时间，我知道这对那些此刻需要听到这些的人来说，将是真正的精神食粮，对于那些即将开启新方向、新生活的人，无论是为了新工作还是新的博士课程，都非常有帮助。非常感谢你的时间。哦，谢谢你，和你交谈总是很美妙，玛丽安。
what an absolute pleasure and a privilege to speak with Francesca Spector today. Thank you so much for your time, Francesca. I honestly feel so good having spoken to her. We've spoken across the years. We've spoken via voice note and email and social media. But it's really lovely to have finally met her in person. Yeah, I hope that you have taken something from our conversation today. I'd love to know what you have taken from it. If you'd like to come and connect with me on socials, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. And there's also the Aspiring Psychologist community on
今天能与弗朗西斯卡·斯佩克特（Francesca Spector）交谈真是莫大的荣幸和特权。非常感谢你的时间，弗朗西斯卡。和她交谈后，我真的感觉非常好。我们多年来一直有交流，通过语音留言、电子邮件和社交媒体。但能最终亲自见到她真是太好了。希望你从我们今天的谈话中有所收获。我很想知道你从中得到了什么。如果你想在社交媒体上与我联系，我到处都是 @DrMarianneTrent。还有一个“有抱负的心理学家”社区，在
Facebook that you're welcome to come and join and share your thoughts about how this has been insightful for you and perhaps for your clients as well and how it will shape your thinking. Please do also connect with Francesca. As she said, she is Chez Spectre on Twitter and on Instagram. There'll be a link for her book, Alonement, How to Be Alone and Absolutely Own It in the show notes too. If you have got any ideas for future podcast episodes, please do get in touch. Even if you think it might not be a podcast episode, sometimes the questions you ask me evoke the idea of a podcast episode, just like today's. I will be back along with your next podcast episode which will be available
Facebook 上，欢迎你加入并分享你的想法，关于这对你以及你的客户有何启发，以及它将如何塑造你的思维。也请务必与弗朗西斯卡联系。正如她所说，她在 Twitter 和 Instagram 上是 @ChezSpectre。她的书《Alonement: How to Be Alone and Absolutely Own It》的链接也会在节目说明中。如果你对未来的播客剧集有任何想法，请务必联系我。即使你认为它可能不适合做成播客，有时你问我的问题也会激发播客剧集的灵感，就像今天这样。我将带着你的下一集播客回来，它将于
from 6 a.m on monday thank you so much for being part of my world and do be kind to yourself take care if you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories
周一早上6点发布。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，请善待自己，保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫贾娜，我是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同故事的内容非常有趣，
and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及人们是如何成为临床心理学家的。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的成为心理学家的道路，这让我充满了信心，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。